I feel like this is such a passion
project for you this film it marks a
return to Bollywood
a foreign film after three years so how
does it feel to be back and what was it
this story in particular that you wanted
to star in and produce well I feel like
this movie is based on a real-life
family that's not like some superstars
or like crazy you know
well-known athletes or anything they're
regular people who are thrown into this
crazy extraordinary circumstance finding
out that their daughter has a terminal
illness and they decide to thrive under
that instead of like succumbing to it
they you know make life so joyous not
just for herself but for themselves and
most marriage is almost 80% of marriages
end up in divorce after you lose a kid
and these two even now at 55 and 57 they
met when they were 16 even now hold
hands and like when they walk into a
room that they look for the other one
every 10 minutes and it's just so
amazing to see such a tight bond between
them that I thought this real life story
was so beautiful and inspiring in the
world that we live in today which is so
sort of distant from each other yeah I
mean it just you guys did such a
wonderful job allowing that to resonate
you know on screen because this is a
real life couple yeah and you portray
this mother this beautiful mother so
authentically the water sky colour jovi
who often Joe because no concept arrow
is that link is your tea canopy of nice
cake a color change good Niki copy Bonet
Harry cop nonce Kyodai but that also
begs the question like is life and gonna
imitate ours are you itching for you
know children soon with with Nick after
experiencing something that was so raw
and real we have played a mother before
in many movies I did it when I was 24 I
don't think that it would be a part that
would make me want to do that but ever
since we've got married we've both known
that you know it's something that we
want and
whenever is the right time I'm sure it
will happen there are so many elements
of this film that I feel like could
resonate to so many people how did this
resonate to you in real life this story
I think it really helped me heal after
my dad's death and who I was really
really close to I think I was so mad at
life and I was just I didn't deal with
it and then I started doing this movie
and shonali who's my director she lost
her son when he was 16 and her
perspective and acceptance of his death
was so amazing to watch and she's she
believes that you know when someone goes
we end up mourning their debts so much
and then we get caught up in the grief
that we forget to celebrate the life
that was lived and that was such an
amazing perspective to me I think this
movie was very cathartic in that way for
me it was healing almost while doing it
I started understanding the balance of
life and that's so much more
[Music]
dashing through the snow
[Music]
this movie has so much heart but it has
a lot of humor - yes I mean you think
like obviously the death of a daughter
that would be something that's gonna be
make this film extremely emotional but
there's so much humor in this film
so one funny law in particular was
something about a chilli pickle - a girl
I'm a Jamaican um but a head and you
call it your will then boyfriend at the
time and you're like that is just that
is the worst joke right so that begs the
question okay what are some of the best
pick-up lines you have ever received
I think pickup lines are so awful it
just goes hard every time someone has a
pick-up line to me it says you're
insecure yeah like don't have a pickup
line
it's so amazing when a guy has the
confidence to be able to come up to you
and be like hi I'm blah blah blah you
know okay so that it did Nick have that
confidence he said into my DMS yeah what
the yeah okay that's bad finesse right
there easy confident all right so did
what kind of game or any lunch was he's
spitting up just like I think you're
beautiful and we need to hang and I was
like that's direct I kind of like this
you know my team has access to my
program why don't you text me I gave and
he was like oh yeah I got her number
it would happen pretty quick oh my gosh
I love it I love it
unbelievable but have you received any
great pickup lines that are just like
stuck with you I'm just don't know now
cuz you're just not into it
trying to pick you up I feel like uh
what else yeah I just I I prefer a
direct conversation are you gonna direct
look into my eyes you know I ignore them
go for it yeah it's so attractive to a
female so you were telling us at the
Toronto Film Festival that this film
legit like wrapped days before your
wedding for days I can't even
but like Nick was super hands on deck
with like helping you with wedding prep
and everything is that who he is is that
true to his nature in real life when
y'all are just chillin at home is he
attending too he's the he's a planner
he's just better at it
yeah but definitely during this movie
because the wedding was in India and the
shoot was in India a lot of the
logistical planning fell on me because
Nick was in America right but I had this
crazy 25 day schedule which shot up to
about four days before the wedding and I
was managing votes so Nick came down
about 20 days before the wedding and he
was just like you focus on your work and
I'll do everything that's last-minute
and him and my mom handled everything I
just wore my outfits and arrived amazing
smiling through my wedding and I enjoyed
it so much because I didn't have to
worry about it he's he's such a
particular planner and everything in our
lives that it's just better when he does
it but that's so nice so when I get to
planning my wedding I'll definitely call
Nick maybe oh yeah you like plan
everything meticulously for you oh
that's so good that's just true to forms
like who he is in real life that really
is reused and I think more so we both
really really respect our our work ethic
and we both know how important our work
is to each other that it's really
important I mean I think for anyone in
any relationship it's really important
to find a partner that can support your
individual ambition or your individual
dreams you know outside of the night and
and let you do that thing and I feel
like that's the healthiest relationship
I could not agree more without a doubt
but how do you find now you guys are so
busy you've got so many films different
projects going on next touring how do
you find balancing being a newlywed and
your busy schedules I guess that's
something we've always known about each
other that our schedules have been crazy
and but we just yeah thank God for video
calling
right FaceTime is a game-changer god
yeah I don't know like I don't I can't
imagine what used to happen before that
but yeah we we make sure we stay in
touch all the time we keep each other
informed about each other's lives that's
really important okay now December is
gonna be here before you know it and
honey that's gonna be your one-year
anniversary y'all had an epic wedding
day so
raishin so I should say wedding
celebrations
[Applause]
[Music]
that being said what is what's the one
year anniversary gonna be with a mine I
don't know I asked and I was told why do
you ask so many questions because he's
the planer so you know he's gotta sleep
okay I'm gonna let you plan it yeah but
yes I was just like what are we gonna do
and he was just like don't ask okay
all right well what's your ideal way to
spend it I would love to make sure we
get time with each other but also with
our family and friends like it's such a
monumental day in both our lives that we
would love to have our loved ones around
us - you were super close to your mom
speaking of that and that's a
relationship that we saw that was super
important and instrumental in the film
so what did your mom say to you about
this film what was her response to it
well my mom is also my producing partner
so she has also produced this movie I
guess we've done a lot of work together
and I think she was just throughout the
movie I remember every five minutes she
just grabbed my hand and like squeezed
it really hard I think every time there
would be a scene she just go she had
that proud mama face and it's just so
amazing to see like when my loved ones
saw the movie my family my mom my
friends like just everyone's reactions
have been so profound and strong with
this with this movie that I feel really
confident in my choice because you were
incredible you may have played a mother
before the girl you were just like it
was next level for you in this film and
I know you were looking for something
that was going to make you nervous yeah
and you could see like your
vulnerability and you were just you
knocked it out of the park so good
finally I'm very excited for you and I
feel for Nick as well because he was
just named season 18 coach on the voice
next season proud wifey over here you've
already been posting up a storm how do
you feel like he is going to have an
edge up on the other judges next season
I don't know if he's gonna have an edge
or not like but I know he's super
competitive and he likes to win is he
super competitive he can be sparring
with Blake yeah I think I think that's
gonna happen I'll have to look
rulz cuz this is my TV show I'm not sure
that you're even old enough to be a
coach on the voice but I'm certain that
you're gonna get your butt kicked buddy
well you saw that when they showed up on
like whatever had the video between him
and Blake at Ellen I mean you saw that
already so I feel like I feel like
that's gonna happen for sure
this week we're like I'm gonna kick your
ass but I'm a huge fan of the voice and
I was really excited when it happened
that's so good you guys have a lot to be
excited about thank you congratulations
on the film it's beautiful okay so as
our youth great job thank you